es war klar dass wir sehr zu beginn der
des jahres schon uns wieder treffen
werden denn die verordnung die wir im
dezember erlassen haben gehen ja nur bis
zum 10
januar und um die vorbereitung treffen
zu können mussten wir uns ein bild von
der lage machen
dazu haben wir gestern eine
expertenanhörung vorgeschaltet bei denen
der chef des robert koch-instituts avila
uns nochmal darauf hingewiesen hat dass
durch die weihnachts und silvester neues
tage eine klare datenlage über die
wirkliche instanz in deutschland erst ab
17 januar etwa zu gewinnen ist das heißt
wir ahnen und wissen dass die incidents
deutlich über 50 ist aber wie genau sie
ist kann zur zeit nicht genau abgesehen
werden
unser ziel bleibt es natürlich weiter
unter 50 infizierte pro 100.000
einwohnern in sieben tagen zu kommen
warum damit die nachverfolgung der
infektionsketten wieder möglich ist
das gewinnt noch einmal an bedeutung
weil wir von einer mutation des virus
kenntnis erlangt haben
aus großbritannien die sich schneller
verbreitet und damit mehr infektionen
pro kontakt verursacht das heißt also
hier müssen wir besonders vorsichtig
sein
daraus entsteht noch mal eine neue und
besondere lage wir haben gestern unter
den experten stellvertretend für die
universitätsklinika professor krömer den
chef der charité in berlin gehört der
uns noch
hingewiesen hat unter welch hoher
belastung die intensivstation in der
bundesrepublik deutschland jetzt
arbeiten und sie wissen dass wir immer
von einer überforderung des
gesundheitswesens ausgegangen von einer
verhinderung der überforderung des
gesundheitswesens ausgegangen sind und
wir sind jetzt sehr sehr stark doch in
grenzsituationen an einigen
krankenhäusern das heißt auch das hat
uns noch einmal dazu bewogen heute
weitreichende beschlüsse zu fassen und
alle die argumente die ich eben vorher
genannt habe wir wollen die beschlüsse
die wir im dezember gefasst haben bis
zum 31 januar verlängern
und wir werden in einigen bereichen die
beschlüsse auch noch einmal verschaffen
müssen aus den gründen die ich geben
genannt habe ein grund ist eben dass die
kontakte noch weiter reduziert werden
müssen weil wir ja auch gesehen haben
dass wir in den letzten wochen eben
nicht so weit die inzidenz senken
konnten wie wir wollten und weil wir
eben durch das virus und seine
mutationen noch einmal unsicherheiten
haben das heißt wir fordern alle
bürgerinnen und bürger auf die kontakte
auf das absolut notwendige minimum zu
beschränken
und wir werden in erweiterung der
bisherigen beschlüsse private
zusammenkünfte im kreis der angehörigen
des eigenen hausstandes und mit maximal
einer weiteren nicht im haushalt
lebenden personen nur gestatten dass es
eine deutliche reduktion gegenüber der
jetzt bestehenden regelung von fünf
personen aus zwei haushalten
wir sehen uns zu dieser rückkehr zu der
märz maßnahme eben aus den genannten
gründen
genötigt und glauben dass sie richtig
ist auch wenn sie für die menschen hart
ist wir wollen dass niemand alleine ist
deshalb eine nicht im haus stand lebende
person aber ansonsten die kontakte
innerhalb des hausstandes wir werden
betriebskantinen schließen wo immer die
arbeitsabläufe das zu lassen
es bleibt die abgabe von mitnahme
fähigen speisen und getränken möglich
aber ein verzehr vor ort wird untersagt
und wir appellieren noch einmal an die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber die
großzügigen home office möglichkeiten
weiter gelten zu lassen oder neue zu
schaffen um den grundsatz wir bleiben zu
hause um auch den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr zu entlasten wirklich
umsetzen zu können
wir haben uns im blick auf die ja schon
früher beschlossene hotspot strategie
was passiert in landkreisen mit über 200
infektionen noch zu einer weiteren
möglichen maßnahmen entschieden nämlich
zur einschränkung des bewegungsradius
auf 15 kilometer um den wohnort herum
sofern kein triftiger grund vorliegt
triftige gründe sind natürlich
arztbesuche oder arbeitsstätten die man
aufsuchen muss insbesondere haben wir
hier im blick das tages touristische
ausflüge keinen triftigen grund
darstellen sie wissen was in bestimmten
regionen jetzt als es geschneit hatte
auch los war und wie viele kontakte da
entstanden sind das muss verhindert
werden
einige bundesländer praktizieren diese
15km regel schon es ist also nicht etwas
ganz neues aber es kann und zu der
hotspots strategien bei instanzen über
200 hinzutreten
wir haben uns noch einmal mit den
pflegeheimen befasst das ist ja bei
weitem nicht das erste mal die
testpflicht gibt es bereits sie gilt
schon einige zeit aber wir haben
festgestellt dass nicht überall diese
test anordnung auch schon ausreichend
durchgeführt werden dass es
ständig ist personalaufstockung
vorzunehmen und hier sind wir sehr
dankbar dass auch die bundesagentur für
arbeit
solche extra teams mit schulen wird um
wirklich sicher zu stellen vor ort das
in allen altenheimen diese test
strategie umfassend umgesetzt wird was
die erstattung der kosten anbelangt so
haben wir seit langem eine großzügige
regelung sowohl für die erstattung der
tests als auch für personalkosten die
zusätzlich notwendig sein werden und wir
haben jetzt noch einmal deutlich gemacht
dass auch einrichtungen der eigentlichen
es hilfe mit dieser initiative erfasst
werden sollen
wir sagen etwas zu der neuen mutation
des virus hier geht es vor allen dingen
darum dass die sequenzierung von viren
verstärkt wird in deutschland dazu wird
im rahmen des dritten bevölkerungsschutz
gesetzes eine zusätzliche verordnung
erlassen werden
wir haben uns sehr lange mit dem thema
impfen beschäftigt richtigerweise denn
wir wissen dass mit den nunmehr
verfügbaren impfstoffen ist eine
perspektive da es für eine
normalisierung unseres alltags und die
rückkehr zu einem leben ohne pandemie
beschränkte einspannen bedingte
einschränkungen und wir haben in diesem
zusammenhang nochmal ausdrücklich
klargestellt dass bund und länder
begrüßen dass es eine gemeinsame
impfstoff bestellung der europäischen
union gibt und dass das ziel den
wirkstoff gemeinsam für alle 27 länder
der eu zu sichern
ein richtiges und wichtiges ziel ist im
übrigen auch ein ziel das im deutschen
interesse liegt dann wir sind umgeben
von vielen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union wir arbeiten in einem
freien binnenmarkt wir haben einen
schengen raum in dem freie bewegung
möglich ist und eine hohe zahl von
kämpfen in deutschland kombiniert mit
vielen die nicht geimpft sind in unserer
nachbarschaft wird
auch nicht zum wohle deutschlands seien
und deshalb wollen wir keine nationalen
alleingänge sondern wir glauben dass der
wirkungsvollste gesundheitsschutz für
uns durch eine gemeinsames europäisches
vorgehen auch erreicht werden erkannt
wir haben in diesem zusammenhang noch
einmal geklärt was natürlich für das
terminmanagement extrem wichtig ist für
die länder
wann kann man voraussagen welche
lieferung bekommt wir haben im
augenblick nur eine zulassung eines
impfstoffs herstellers bei und ex kaiser
es werden andere dazu kommen wir wissen
allerdings nicht wann wie viele und
werden aber sicherstellen dass dann wenn
impfstoff auch da ist wirklich dieser
auch verimpft werden kann und das bedarf
natürlich ein höchstmaß an
berechenbarkeit ohne dass wir den
zulassungsbehörden in diesem fall der
europäischen zulassungsbehörde
vorgreifen können das ist natürlich auch
klar
haben sie eine ganze reihe von fragen
gestellt
wir werden im ersten quartal nur
priorisierte gruppen impfen können das
ist aber auch gar keine neue erkenntnis
wir werden dann im zweiten quartal nach
menschlichem ermessen und nach allem was
wir von den herstellern wissen deutlich
mehr impfdosen bereits haben und das
wird sich dann im 2
im zweiten quartal und im dritten
quartal natürlich noch einmal fortsetzen
insgesamt hat die europäische union
deutlich mehr impfstoff bestellt als
notwendig ist um alle menschen in der
europäischen union zu impfen
ein wichtiger punkt der betrieb von
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen und
schulen
hier haben wir
uns entschieden dass die von den ländern
ergriffenen maßnahmen entsprechenden
beschluss vom 13 dezember bis ende
januar verlängert werden auch das wissen
wir dass das eine harte entscheidung ist
aber wir halten sie für notwendig weil
es mit sich bringt dass eltern auf ihre
kinder auch zu hause aufpassen müssen
dass sie selber betreuen müssen
verlängern oder wiederholen wir die
regelung die wir schon für das jahr 2020
hoffen dass nämlich eltern je elternteil
zehn zusätzliche zu den rechtlich schon
bestehenden zehn tagen für die betreuung
von kindern bekommen das gilt
normalerweise wenn die kinder krank sind
den zweck erweitern wir wenn man die
panini pandemie bedingt der zugang zum
kinderbetreuungsangebot eingeschränkt
ist oder die präsenzpflicht im
unterricht ausgesetzt ist das heißt also
dass eltern die aus gründen einer wenn
es bedingten zugangs zu schulen oder
kindertagesstätten oder wegen
geschlossener schulen ihre kinder zu
hause betreuen müssen dann diese tage
die sonst nur für kranke kinder in
anspruch genommen werden können
auch in anspruch nehmen können und dass
diese tage auch verdoppelt werden
ja sagen noch etwas zu den finanziellen
kompensationen die natürlich mit
hochdruck gearbeitet werden weil wir
wissen was für geschlossene geschäfte
restaurants usw
die ausfälle bedeuten hier arbeiten bund
und länder eng zusammen und versuchen
die dinge soweit es möglich ist zu
beschleunigen und wir werden bei
einreisen aus risikogebieten eine
doppelt test strategie einführen
das heißt man muss bei einreise einen
test vorweisen dann aber trotzdem in
quarantäne gehen und es kann sich dann
nach dem fünften tag wieder frei testen
lassen so wie das bis heute auch schon
ist das ist sehr wichtig wir hatten
jetzt wieder sehr großen reiseverkehr
über weihnachten und in diesem bereich
der offenen grenzen aber der sehr großen
risikogebiete um uns
warum ist das wichtig um den eintrag zu
verringern
wir werden uns am 25 januar wieder
treffen um dann zu schauen wo wir stehen
die maßnahmen die wir heute geschlossen
haben sind einschneidend sie sind nicht
nur die fortsetzung dessen was wir vor
weihnachten getan haben sondern sie sind
angesichts der lage härter gerade was
kontakt beschränkungen anbelangt zum
teil auch was in hotspots
bewegungsmöglichkeiten anbelangt was die
schulen und kitas anbelangt die
fortsetzung ist auch eine große
herausforderung für eltern und die
kinder natürlich aber wir sehen uns dazu
genötigt um unser ziel nicht aus den
augen zu verlieren
ich habe immer wieder gesagt die
wintermonate sind das haben uns die
experten gestern noch einmal gesagt die
monate in denen die pandemie am
stärksten wüteten kann mit der
kombination des mutierten virus das auch
schon bei uns eingetragen wurde
es ist absolut notwendig und deshalb
müssen wir zu einem punkt kommen wo wir
die infektionsketten wieder
nachvollziehen können denn ansonsten
können wir immer nur nach einer kurzen
lockerung wieder zurückgehen in einen
lock down und umsatz zu verhindern ist
der versuch jetzt wichtig wirklich noch
mal deutlich runter zu kommen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren